hello everyone my name is Miguel Makarov
today I will talk about expanded
decomposition Dynamics things
this is Joint work with Michael kapralf
and iron filter
do you understand what expander
decomposition is first I need to
introduce some definitions
you say that g is a graph on N vertices
and a matches
and for this gravity a cut s is just
some subset of the vertices
there's a couple of useful definition
measures for a cut test
first is its volume s and the volume of
s is just equal to the sum of degrees of
your business
another useful definition is the
size of a cut
which I denote by double G as complement
of F and this is the number of edges
connecting s and complement of s
finally the most important definition
the sparsity workout
sparsity is equal to its size
divided by 2 the volume of the smaller
cut of the size for example on this
picture this blue cut has size 3 because
it cuts three edges
and it's smaller site
on the right has volume 5. so the smart
city is three over five
besides that graph G is a fee expander
before all Cuts in G there's RCT is at
least five
expander have a lot of useful properties
one that'd be useful for us in the stock
is that the diameter of Pi expanders is
bounded by of logarithm of n divided by
Phi
well unfortunately not all graphs are
good expanders
for example uh consider this graph here
this blue cut has only size one
while both volumes of both of the sites
are
hello to the large however each graph
can be decomposed into a union of
expanders while keeping the number of
inter-cluster edges fairly small
now this is basically the definition of
expanded decomposition and more formally
we call a Vertex partition C and
expander an Epson Phi expanded
decomposition if each cluster in C is a
Phi expander
and the number of inter-cluster edges is
at least the most absent times the
volume of the whole graph
and the
expanded decomposition can be
seen as a natural clustering of a graph
with respect to its uh expand expansion
or sparse team
how can one construct one such an
expanded decomposition well
the simplest algorithm is as follows we
fix some
spar ct5
and afterwards we find the cut injury
with the smallest sparsity
if this particle is still bigger than 5
then J is a Phi expander so we can
return it as a singular cluster in the
expanded composition
otherwise we recourse on both of the cut
sizes and then return the union of the
results
of the calls
one can see that this results in
expanded decomposition where each
clusters of fire expander by
construction and one can also show that
the fraction of the inter cluster edges
is bounded by all of five times
logarithm one
this is known to be the best possible
trade-off between Epson Phi
so there is nothing period to be
imported here
how can one use an expanded
decomposition uh
in other settings well
consider the question of constructing a
distance Oracle
I simply simplify a little bit we say
that
Ash graph Ash is a key distance Oracle
of G for all pair of vertices need the
distance between them in G
is at least at most the distance between
them and H which is in turn at most T
times the distance between some injury D
is called the stretch parameter of the
distance Oracle and the usually when one
constructs a distance Oracle one wants
to have as little edges as possible in h
while still having a relatively small
chip
so if one if is given an Epson Phi
exposure decomposition one can construct
the distance Oracle with stage of log n
over Phi and the number of edges bounded
by Epsilon times M plus m
the contraction of this false it calls
that expanders have bound a diameter of
log n over file so we can replace each
expander in the expanded decomposition
with a weighted start where weight of
each Edge is equal to this Upper
Mountain diameter while keeping all of
the interquasterers
so now we hopefully understand what an
expanded decomposition is now what is a
dynamic stream this is a fairly simple
definition
in a dynamic stream one is given graph G
as a sequence of updates
and each update either adds an he that
wasn't in the graph or deletes an energy
that was in the graph
and the goal in Dynamic streams is
usually to solve some problem using
memory sublinear in the number of edges
on the graph because otherwise one can
just restore the whole graph in the
memory and solve the problem after the
Stream
de facto a standard approach in this
setting is to use linear sketches and it
was first used in this manner by Anne
McGregor
and for example in their other work they
showed that one can construct the cast
specifier in sublinear in a memory using
those linear sketches
speaking of previous work
there are no material results not for
contacting expander decomposition in
Dynamic stream setting so I will talk
about
the ram Model A little bit
in the ram model
one of the earliest
works on constructing expanded
decomposition was by schpermanent where
they shown that uh in exponential time
one can uh achieve the best known uh
trade-off uh
and their algorithm is a refinement of
the algorithm that I mentioned before
uh
for a long uh foreign
one can achieve a trade-off between
Epsilon 5 that is just
uh this is what is the best possible
only by logarithm square of n
and this result was recently improved by
Agassi dolphin in Japan
to have only logarithm of n overhead
over the best possible Traders
in our work we show that there exists a
of file login file expander
decomposition algorithm in Dynamic
streams that uses only linear in N over
five squared memory
but uses exponential time
right so this has two interesting one
interesting color corollary that is uh
one can actually construct a with
achieve the best possible trade-off
between Epsilon Phi in a dynamic stream
and another calorie states that now that
we have this exponential time expanded
decomposition section we can use it to
construct the distance Oracle uh with
good parameters in in a dynamic stream
we also give a polynomial time algorithm
which has a worse
quality trade-off between Epsilon 5 and
uses super linear and memory but that
still can be made sublinear in m
foreign
for the remainder of my talk I will talk
about the tools that we use to achieve
this first I will introduce the concept
of power cut specifier which proved to
be very useful for
constructing an expanded decomposition
and then we will talk a little bit about
the algorithm itself and the how it
works
okay let's start
we are so to understand why we need a
power cut specifier let's try to solve
some easier problems first now let's
start let's start with expander testing
so imagine that we are giving G in a
dynamic stream and after we are giving a
parameter five
and our goals to distinguish if G was an
a fire expander or or had some vice
versa in it
this can be done using a Delta cut
specifier so we say that g Prime is a
Delta cast specifier of dream if for all
cut s
their size is approximately the same
in G and G Prime up to one plus minus
Delta multiplicative Factor
as I mentioned before G Prime is
computable in linear in nearly linear in
N over a Delta space dot Squarespace
McGregor
and the
one can also notice that if G is a fire
expander J Prime would be a
one plus minus Delta Phi expander
because the
expansion the sparsity of a cut depends
only on the size of the cut which is
plus minus a lot to preserved in the cut
specifier as well as the volumes of the
cut Cycles which can be shown are also
one plus minus Delta preserved
so this is for simple solution we just
construct a Delta cat specifier and
check the if it's a five specified
expander or not
okay let's try to apply the same uh
approach to a different problem
testing if a clustering C is an expanded
decomposition and here we are given G in
the direction then crucially only after
the step I'll be giving this partition C
and values for an Epsilon
and our goal is to check if Phi is an
Epson Phi expandedly is an Epson Phi
expanded decomposition
so for this problem uh if you try to uh
use the regular cat specifier
you would run in the following into the
following issue that we would have to
check for each subgraph
if it is uh
Phi expander or not
and
for a subgraph it is not known if
a cut specifier preserves the size sizes
of cuts right
so we would like to have the following
strength ring of a cast specifier and
that that is a gravity Prime such that
for every possible cluster C in view
G Prime uh restricted to this cluster C
would be a cast specifier object
restricted to this clusters
however such a
specifier G Prime would have to have a
almost the same number of edges so as
the original graph which would render it
basically users and the reason is pretty
simple so consider any two vertices u
and v in the graph
right if you now restrict our G Prime to
those two vertices
then by checking the only non-trivial
cut that separates U and B in the
subgraph we could determine if
the original gravity had an edge e or
not right so that would imply that g
Prime would have to have at least this
approximately the same number of edges
as G
which implies that it would
have to have a lot of address this is
and that's that's bad for our purposes
however we don't exactly need
a guarantee uh
a purely multiplicative guarantee for
the cut size preservation to check the
sparsity you can relax to have a
additive error also in the volume of a
cut so for example
we say that g Prime is a Delta Epsilon
gas specifier if you press one plus
minus Delta multiplicative error in the
size of a cut itself
as well as additive error
in
uh
between
1 plus minus Epsilon times the volume of
a cut test
and that's pretty easy to see that if G
is a Phi expander then J Prime would be
an 1 plus minus Delta times Phi plus
minus Epsilon expander itself
that would allow us to check that g is a
Phi expander if well Epson was
because the relatively small and
compared to five
in this Construction
and similarly to the
uh strengthening that I proposed earlier
we can strengthen this concept to the
concept of Delta Epsilon power cut
specifier where
for each partition C you would want with
high probability that for all clusters
in this partition G Prime reduced to
each cluster would be an Delta Epsilon
cut specifier of J restricted to this
cluster
okay and if you had such a power cast
specifier then the solution to our
expanded decomposition testing could be
pretty simple
you will just construct G Prime
then we would check the sparsity of all
of the cuts
in each cluster and then you would make
our decision
however there's one problem how to
construct such a cut specifier
well let's take a step back and look at
how
specifiers are constructed in general
first uh
people Define some kind of edge
importance for a church depending on the
kind of
the properties that they want to
preserve from the specifier for example
we can take just reverse such
connectivity right then this importance
is multiplied by some factors to get
sample probability PE for for each
then each Edge is sampled with its
probability
and the same way
equal to 1 over P if it survives the
sampling
in our case we say we said the sampling
probability to be proportional to the
sum of inverse degree of the edge
endpoints
and this is a good
for two reasons first this is a very
simple uh
importance measures to compute even in a
dynamic stream
and second this
sampling probability was considered
earlier by Spillman and tank and they
shown that
sampling with this probability would
produce a cat specifier if we were to
apply this procedure to an expander
so bottom line is that uh
power cut specifier while while being a
new object is not exactly a new object
by itself but just a
more fine fine finally great analyzed uh
previously existing objects
okay so now let's take a look at how our
algorithm actually works a little bit
closer
so one if one were to think about how to
construct an expanded decomposition in
Dynamic streams now one could try the
following approach just compute the
power cast specified Prime
and construct an expanded decomposition
with
hoping that because with hyperability
this expanded decomposition can be
verified
as a power cast specifier Then it could
be an expanded decomposition of the
original graph
however there is one problem and that is
uh
the high probability uh
property of the power cast specifier
only holds if the partition
was chosen independently of the power
cast specifier and this uh is not the
case here because the partition is
very much depends on the power has
specified itself so we cannot use this
approach
so we can try something else
okay recall the recursive approach that
I mentioned in the beginning of the talk
you take our graph we find the graph
with the
we make this cut we occurs on the sub
graph and so on
so what we can do is that we can take a
graph specifier G prime one use it to
find as the spices cut in it
then recurs on the subgraphs but for the
subgraphs use a different cut specifier
G Prime 2.
and uh and so on until if we can verify
that the graph is a expander itself
this works but this have one this has
one problem and that is the total memory
used to be the number
the the depth of the
of this procedure times the memory
needed to store one
cut specifier
so to achieve
new almost linear memory and then the
depth must be poly logarithmic again
and the simple algorithms that I
mentioned earlier doesn't uh has have
this guarantee so we need to
improve the algorithm a little bit
so we would we use something called the
cat matching glamor and this lever is a
member of a family of lemons with
similar granges the guarantees looks
like this
so there exists an hour version which
Shakes as an input like a graph G and
sparsity Phi and it returns one to the
following it can declare that g is an o5
expander
or it can return a graph with partial
lesson Phi but that is a fairly balanced
one in terms of the volume that is the
volume of the above side is
approximately the same
or it can return a graph a test that has
a spice less than five and that doesn't
exactly has the
that doesn't necessarily has the
guarantees that it's balanced in the
volume
but it can give us some property on the
bigger side of the cat
and
this property can be a lot of different
things
well the strongest one that this uh that
people can get if they apply this
that matching glamor approach to a
graphing a
classical model is that the bigger size
of a cat is the alpha expander this was
shown by Spillman attack and in this
case we can just stop our recursive
algorithm at this point
and uh
yes this would bound the total depth by
of Logan
if you don't want to pay exponential
time
uh
others the case is the first type of
guarantee
the guarantee that we can get is all
fear expand is the bigger side of a cat
is nearly all the expander
and uh there we can
there's also a possibility to get a
weaker guarantee yeah that just that the
bigger side of a cut
doesn't have a
a cat that is comparable
that is bigger in volumes at our cut
and has sparsity atmosphere
and as it turns out uh in our session
because we use card specifiers to find
the cuts we cannot really make you get a
cut matching plumber that gets as a
stronger and he likes the first one
but we can only get something similar to
the Third uh guarantee and that's
basically all I wanted to say about our
algorithm now let me talk about some
open problems the first open problem
problems is to try to remove dependence
on uh parameter file and we are working
on it right now
so stay tuned
the second proper problem is uh try to
improve the
quality trade-off for the polynomial
time algorithm
preferably to match the ones that we get
in a classical setting
and finally uh it could be very
interesting to construct an algorithm
that would allow the stream to be
adaptive that is a setting where we are
required to Output our expanded
decomposition at some point in the
Stream and then continue to refuse
updates
and that's all I wanted to talk about
thank you for your attention